[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben in diesem video zeige
ich euch das rezept für leckere und
saftige nussecken das rezept ist für 32
nussecken ausgelegt und sofern ihr sie
luftdicht verpackt und gelagert sind sie
bis zu drei wochen haltbar
sofern sie denn so lange halten denn ich
bin mir sicher ihr von der strecke
vorher schon starten wir zuallererst mit
dem mürbeteig dafür benötigen wir mehl
butter zucker und backpulver die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in meine info box und dem
mittag wird nun so zubereitet in dem wir
alle zutaten miteinander vermischen
ich gehe dabei so vor dass ich zuerst
die trockenen zutaten in eine schüssel
geben sie mit den händen ganz kurz
vermenge und dann gebe ich die butter
und die eier mit dazu die butter ist
übrigens zimmer warm so lässt sich das
ganze viel leichter verkneten und in
nicht mal fünf minuten weil man merkt
dann auch schon fertig und es kann ans
auslegen gehen
hierfür nehme ich mir meinen mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
ich habe da noch einen eckigen back
rahmen drum herum gelegt damit das ganze
auch einen schönen abschluss hat falls
ihr so einen aber nicht habt ist das gar
kein problem dann lasst ihn einfach
[Musik]
sobald der mac dann gleichmäßig auf dem
backblech verteilt wurde sticht ihr mit
einer gabel ein paar mal ein damit der
teig beim backen auch nicht hochgeht
damit der mürbeteig schön festwirt und
beim backen mit dem belag nicht
ineinander gerät es ist jetzt ganz
wichtig dass sie ihn für 30 minuten
kühlt in der zwischenzeit machen wir
weiter mit der füllung wir benötigen
aprikosenmarmelade außerdem gemeinde
lüste sowie gehackte nüsse ihr könnt da
komplett frei entscheiden welche nimmt
ich habe mich hierfür gemahlene mandeln
und gehackte haselnüsse entschieden
außerdem noch butter und zucker etwas
wasser und vanillezucker und weiter
geht's auf dem herd und hier wird
zuallererst die butter geschmolzen und
das wasser hinzugegeben die videosequenz
mit dem wasser die seht ihr leider nicht
die hat meine kamera nicht mit
aufgenommen das ist aber ganz wichtig
für die konsistenz gibt es auf jeden
fall mit dazu und dann gebe ich noch den
weißen zucker und den vanillezucker mit
hinzu und lasse das ganze einmal ganz
kurz aufkochen kocht die butter am
besten langsam auf und nimmt nicht
gleich die höchste stufe damit euch die
butter auf keinen fall anbrennt nachdem
das ganze dann noch mal aufgekocht ist
schalte ich den herd aus und gebe die
nüsse mit dazu ich nehme mal einen teil
gemahlene und ein teil gehackte nüsse
welche müsste das sind das ist
vollkommen euch überlassen
ich selbst entscheide das auch jedes mal
kurz vorher aus dem bauch heraus der
nuss belag kommt jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz an die seite denn es geht weiter
mit dem gekühlten mürbeteig
da wird jetzt die aprikosenmarmelade
drauf gestrichen und ich nehme da immer
gerne sehr viel aprikosenmarmelade denn
je mehr davon benutzt desto saftiger
werben den musiken ich würde die grenze
von 350 gramm allerdings nicht
überschreiten nicht nur immer ganz gerne
300 gramm
[Musik]
anschließend wird der nuss belag darüber
verteilt und schön verstrichen
[Musik]
nachdem der belag schön glatt
verstrichen wurde kommt die nussecken
bei 175 grad ober und unterhitze in den
vorgeheizten backofen führt ca 30
minuten
hier könnt ihr ganz gut erkennen dass
man offen sehr ungleichmäßig backt das
tut dem geschmack aber gar keinen
abbruch ich hab die nussecken jetzt
vollständig auskühlen lassen
ca 2 stunden und jetzt schneide ich sie
durch nun geht ihr so vor dass ihr das
blech einmal halbiert und die halbierten
stücke dann noch einmal halbiert so
erhaltet ihr viel gleichmäßig große
stücke
[Musik]
senkrecht wird das blech dann auch noch
mal in vier gleichmäßige teile
geschnitten und wenn ihr die
entstandenen rechtecke dann noch mal
schräg halbiert dann erhaltet ihr eure
nussecken
[Musik]
unsere fertigen nussecken werden jetzt
noch mit kuvertüre bestrichen
entweder nimmt ihr euch dafür einen
pinsel und bestreicht jeweils eine
hälfte des ecken mit geschmolzener
kuvertüre oder die zweite variante und
die bevorzuge ich immer hier nimmt die
gesamte nussecke und tunkt sie in eure
geschmolzene kuvertüre und so habt ihr
auch viel mehr schokolade an den ecken
[Musik]
nachdem die kuvertüre dann ausgehärtet
ist sind eure nussecken auch schon
fertig falls ihr die saftigen und
aromatischen nussecken jetzt nachbacken
möchtet dann schaut gerne mal in die
infobox da habe ich alle zutaten für
euch aufgeschrieben und ich wünsche euch
dann ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken
falls ihr ein weiteres leckeres rezept
für nussecken sehen möchtet dann schaut
doch gerne mal bei der lieben claudia
von beckinger vorbei sie hat heute
nämlich auch ganz zufällig ihr rezept
für nussecken hochgeladen und ich bin
selbst eine sehr treue abonnenten von
ihrem bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]